hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren ich freue mich in einer gewissen
Form extrem auf das heutige Video denn
ich werde heute schauen was für ein
großer Idiot ich bin
und ich schätze mich da schon relativ
gut mit dabei ein
Sprachen lernen Babbel los geht's mit
dem ersten von drei IQ Tests die wir
heute machen werden wie viel Liter
Treibstoff passt in ein Flugzeug
da ist meine Fluglinie bis zu 220.000
Liter bis zu 189
000 Liter ist super eine halbe Millionen
Liter oder bis zu 350 000 ich mache
wieder den typischen wir gehen irgendwo
in die Mitte guck mal Frage Nummer zwei
wie viele Entenarten gibt es
[Musik]
wir ignorieren die Bilder ab jetzt ich
würde sagen es gibt bis zu 50 Enden
Arten 100
und was hat das mit meinem IQ zu tun wie
viele Kilogramm Code scheidet ein
Elefant am Tag aus das Bild kommt
ich werde die Bilder ab jetzt alle
ignorieren ich würde sagen in Elefant
scheißt 13 Kilo am Tag weil das ist so
eine
alle Zahlen waren so schön mit so einer
fünf oder einer Null deswegen dachte ich
nehme die 13 aber okay sind Eisbären
Linkshänder war oder falsch diese
Aussage boah Bilder einfach von 2002
oder so sind Eisbären Linkshänder ich
würde sagen nein als ob jeder Eisbär die
gleiche
[Musik]
du willst mir sagen dass jeder
verdammter scheiß Eisbär auf der ganzen
Welt mit Links sich den kackfisch fängt
wie viel Gramm wiegt ein Federball boah
Federball also entweder bei wiegt nicht
so schon mal falsch weil der jedes alles
hat ein Gewicht
ich würde sagen boah das Ding ist so
leicht das auf jeden Fall das kleinste
so fett vorletzte Frage im ersten Quiz
wie viel Tonnen kann die Wilma
randerbrücke tragen
boah das ist alles gar nicht mal so viel
ne 50 Tonnen sind nicht mal 50 Autos
nicht mal 50 kleinwagen sind 50 Tonnen
das heißt die Brücke
Wilma Branda die gibt's doch gar nicht
[Musik]
da bin ich wieder letzte Frage wie viele
Buchstaben hat das Wort okay ist ja easy
muss man einfach nur zählen
boah ich hasse euch so doll ne
[Musik]
war die höchste Zahl ich war eh schon
über 60 und es gibt nichts unter 60
schauen wir mal raus wie ich
abgeschnitten habe wen sie können den
später schauen wir uns vielleicht doch
nicht an alle aus der Lukas
wahrscheinlich schon gecheckt diese IQ
Tests die ich hier gerade mache haben
mal wieder drei Fanpages für mich
erstellt zum Beispiel das was wir gerade
gemacht haben war dieses Jahr das
bombastische loser Quiz von Jessie aka
con unterstrich lugi und wir machen auch
direkt weiter mit dem zweiten der drei
Tests und zwar dem IQ Test für dumme von
Malin aka
lugi_lo_lou welches Fragezeichen passt
nicht Frage Nummer eins was nicht passt
ist äh
[Musik]
oh
merken für später dann frage Nummer zwei
wie viele Dreiecke sind auf dem Bild zu
sehen okay wir haben ein Team OT haben
wir bisher eins zwei drei vier fünf
sechs blaue 1 2 3 also 9 ein ganz großes
sind zehn hier haben wir 11 12 13 13
mit Ansage in diesem Quiz alles richtig
gibt es in England den 17 Juni
ja klar warum nicht
[Musik]
als ob die den einfach überspringen am
Handy uns ja in ein paar Jahren einfach
einen Monat voraus welcher Buchstabe
fehlt
MDMA Montag Dienstag Mittwoch Donnerstag
den
ich bin so ein verdammter Jeep so
unfassbar wir hatten bisher übrigens als
Buchstabe OTO und hier ist ein K das
müssen wir uns also auch noch merken was
ergibt 7 x 7 49
[Musik]
die Sache ist das alles in diesem
Zusammenhang hier gerade richtiges außer
weil sieben mal sieben also
multipliziert ist 49 in diesem Bild ist
7 x 7 ein Fragezeichen weil 7 x 7 =
Fragezeichen und 7 mal 7 ergibt auch
ganz feinen Sand wenn man Sand sieht das
heißt egal was hier passiert
ich ich nehme jetzt das nicht
entscheiden
oh mein Gott
aber richtig tricky weil diese beiden
Sachen werden auch richtig gewesen
Nummer sechs welches Tier kann höher
springen als der Eiffelturm ich glaube
alle Tiere weil der Eiffelturm nicht
springen kann ich
so krass ich hatte einfach bisher alles
richtig ich hoffe du hast aufgepasst ich
habe mir auch alle Buchstaben gemerkt
nenne das Lösungswort
ich bin so krank ich habe noch nie eine
siebente Antwort Serie letzte Frage dein
IQ beträgt okay das ist jetzt irgendwie
wieder so eine lustige Frage ja okay
[Musik]
auch gefährliches Bild von mir was hier
am Start ist ich schwöre euch das wird
die höchste Punktzahl sein die ich je in
einem kahoot Quiz erreicht habe und ihr
wisst ich habe schon einige gemacht
locker 8 Stück oder so ich habe 7.800
oh Gott
[Musik]
Leute macht Screenshot
rammt es euch ein Stück das Weltrekord
Buch kommen nun allerdings auch schon
zum letzten IQ-Test für heute und zwar
dem Quiz für Idioten von Mona aka V
Lords ich bin so gespannt auf dieses
Quiz ne im ersten wurde ich vierter im
zweiten wurde ich erster deswegen mal
schauen welches Quadrat ergänzt die
obige Reihe also wir müssen wieder
schauen
wir haben hier rechts und da hier
tauschen die sich hier so ach ergänzen
ja dann das
[Musik]
habe ich irgendeine Krankheit dass ich
solche Rätsel immer richtig habe eine
halbe Glatzer 2000 Haare wie viele hat
dann eine ganze null
wir raschen das ja auch wieder komplett
durch was ist beim Elefanten klein und
beim floh groß
augenkörperzellen dass das
[Musik]
die Bilder
da also die Mutter von Mann im Mond
hatte drei Kinder Lahr Lee und den Mann
im Mond
ich bin krass
da oben dieser Mond
dieser Gesicht
ich glaube wir sind uns alle einig dass
er aussieht wie ein Mondgesicht
oder wie Thomas die Lokomotive
das könnte auch sein Frage Nummer 5 von
9 auf welcher Straße ist noch keiner
Gefahren auf der Milchstraße
[Musik]
das ist so krass
ich bin so krass ich habe mir nicht mehr
die anderen Antwortmöglichkeiten
durchgelesen weil ich euch schon
durchschaue was brennt Tag und Nacht
ohne selbst zu verbrennen Brennessel
naja die Sonne
brennt auch Tag und Nacht
wenn wir uns nachts auf der anderen
Seite Tag aber ich denke mal Brennessel
weil sowas denkt ihr nicht somit bin
sogar schlauer als ihr das letzte Frage
auf welcher Weide grast keine Kuh auf
der Augenweide
ich bin zu krass wir machen direkt
weiter mich interessieren gar nicht die
punktestelle von den anderen was geht
übers Wasser und wird nicht nass
[Musik]
ohne drauf zu gucken was geht übers
Wasser und wird nicht nass Jesus
[Musik]
oder eine Brücke eine Brücke kann aber
nass werden wegen Regen
jesus kann auch nass werden mit Regen
was geht übers Wasser und wird nicht
nass ein Mensch auf einem Boot der wird
auch bei Regen nass es wird alles bei
Regen lassen Wasserläufer auch
und ein Mensch auf dem Boot geht auch
nicht was Wasser sondern das Boot fährt
er geht nur auf dem Boot jesus ist der
einzige der wirklich geht
das ist doch eine Brücke geht nicht eine
Brücke existiert über dem Wasser aber
sie geht ja nicht letzte Frage welchen
Wert hat das rote Sechseck
gelb hat fünf fünf
da das heißt
Schlaganfall
das ist ja so affig ne komm gib mir den
ersten Platz
erster Platz Video vorbei mit Ansage
erster Platz wie du vorbei Sascha meine
Dank fürs zuschauen danke Jessy Marlin
und Mona für die quizzes das Daumen hoch
da haut
[Musik]
[Applaus]